how long you guys I'm gonna ask Cara how
long you guys been together for real
last June how'd you meet shot be calm
Charlie Commons an arranged marriage
website it's like he's like eHarmony
calm we're not [ __ ] around how'd you
guys actually meet bumble it's the least
cute [ __ ] ever oh that's so cute
algorithms yeah that's nothing cute
about that they don't even think it's
cute that's why they lied the whole time
[Applause]
how drunk are you do you think bumble is
cute girl you're are you need to hurry
up and get married your standards are
dropping every day oh if bumble got cute
to you you better find somebody you're
married well how the [ __ ] did you guys
meet do you think bumbles dude oh no man
she made it hard to make fun of heard
that sweet ass answer I [ __ ] hated
that do it I was I was try to find it
and like make fun of her she's like no
but they're alone
[ __ ] good point have an ass [ __ ] yo man
your girl is sweet you're very drunk but
she's also a sweet yeah did you go to
Texas Tech no you said that [ __ ] like I
don't even go to college
huh I'm on to something I figured I
figured I know a country ass white boy
and I see a country as a white boy he
got on the trucker hat he got sunglasses
on his chest for no reason
my man is radio he goes straight from
here to the tractor not even a [ __ ]
yeah let's go be good
[Music]
crops now going to kill themselves hot
so how did you guys meet that you think
bumble is romantic did you see this
[ __ ] unless over in I'll take that one
right there yeah how did you guys meet
but what were y'all hunting for Mexicans
[Music]
[Applause]
no more trouble you know good and
goddamn well they weren't baptizing
anybody tell the wall comes up this what
the [ __ ] he's gotta be
on the river oh [ __ ] you know you guys
deserve love to a manhole anybody hate
on it there's a nice little [ __ ]
redhead love you guys
[Music]